You've seen the good version in
Wreck-It Ralph.
You skipped the Will Ferrell version in
Megamind.
Now, get ready for the most OK version
of the animated villain becomes a hero story in:
Despicable Me 1 and 2!
Meet Gru,
a terrorist who's just likeable enough
to keep the audience on his side.
"(coin clangs)"
He's got severe depression.
A plan that will kill everyone on Earth,
"Stealing the Moon?!"
and a really funny voice so
you won't dwell to hard on those things.
"You will not cry,
or laugh, or giggle!"
"(giggles)"
Enter a world where villains and spy's lurk
just below the surface.
Or rather ride on top of the surface
where everyone can see.
Where the evil plots are straight
out of Carmen Sandiego.
"The Great Pyramid of Giza
had been stolen!"
"and replaced by
a giant inflatable replica."
But the bad guys draw
the line at robbery?
"I really don't see how
we can afford this."
"I'll just get another one
from the bank."
And the police straight up
don't exist,
which is too bad,
because Gru kills a lot of people.
"(screams)"
"(screaming)"
"(clang)"
"(tire screech)"
"(ray firing)"
"(whirring)"
"(kids cheering)"
"(rumbling)"
"I've got it!
I've got the moon!!!"
(Alarm blazing)
In Despicable Me,
ride along as Gru adopts three little girls
with three old grandma names.
"Margo, Edith and Agnes"
In the short but sweet kids' movie
with heart and humour.
"(grunts and groans)"
Then watch Despicable Me 2,
a 90-minute rehash of the first one
with war of what kids really want.
Minion fart jokes.
"(fart sound, chuckles)"
"(gibberish, fart sound)"
Haha, get it?
The Minion did the fart noise.
See Pixar? This is exactly
what was missing from Up.
(fart)
Witness the tragedy of a man slowly losing
his franchise to his underlings.
As the minions go from cute little
interludes between scenes.
To having their own B-story.
To getting a spin-off movie that's bigger
than Despicable Me's ever were.
To becoming the unofficial mascot
of your crazy aunt's Facebook page.
What do the minions have
to do with vaccines?
What is wrong with you Aunt Pam?
So kick back and enjoy the franchise
you love to hate.
Not because the movies are bad,
but because you can't get away
from the ad campaigns.
The crappy spin-offs.
Or that Pharrell song
you liked at first.
Until it burrowed into your brain
like a molly soaked tapeworm.
Damn it, it's back in my head again!
Hey, you stole that nacho hat
from The Simpsons!
You don't own everything yellow
and bald, you know!
Hey, Screen Junkies,
if you even more Despicable Me,
watch us show Steve Carell, Kristen Wiig,
and the cast of the movie, some real Despicable Memes,
on this week, Screen Junkies Show.
Click below to check it out.